are there different sets of rules into
for breaking into reality television vs
or is it salt still the same it's the
the one big difference in terms of
breaking in the reality is that if you
are a person who the audience wants to
see filmed like the Kardashians then yes
you can jump right into it otherwise no
and keep in mind reality shows are
created they are written we you know we
call them reality shows but they're
anything but reality shows so but
they're the people who are shaping the
story throughout the season are the
producers and so they say they create a
framework for these quote real people to
operate within but because that
framework is determined by them and
because they are constantly coming up
with story ideas to generate conflict
within that framework they are in effect
working as writers although they are not
paid that way so the process then for
being a writer on a reality show which
doesn't be the same that's what you've
mentioned previously been too it's it's
the same in the sense of that you have
to pay your dues and you have to start
by getting on a show and working on a
show and then once you again once you're
inside the walls and you're paying your
dues then you're given more and more
power you move up what is a very
stratified system in terms of what
you're allowed to do and if the higher
you move up as a producer the more
creative power you have
you